hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before
friday monday morning podcast and i'm
just checking in on you
i'm just checking in on you how's it
going how are you
are you doing all right you know
something i actually have a [ __ ] bone
to pick with all these
nhl fans out there who keep telling me
don't worry
don't worry the canadians are gonna lose
the next
round don't worry t uh
you know toronto has they got them right
where they want them they're going to
win the game six they're going to win
the game
seven toronto is a loser organization
winnipeg's gonna wipe the [ __ ]
floor with them mop the floor with them
they [ __ ] sweep winnepec
now they're playing vegas all right now
they're with the big boys the first
couple of rounds you know you can be a
decent team
you can sneak through yadda yadda yadda
and what happens vegas goes out wins the
first game four to one or something like
that pretty handily
pretty and then last night
i watched the canadies come out and they
just [ __ ] jumped on them
and they look like two very evenly
matched teams
and uh i gotta tell you something i'm
done listening to other people giving me
false hope
you know i feel like waiting for the
canadians to leave
is like when they when your flight is
delayed and they just go we're gonna
board in another 15 minutes
15 minutes later it's just gonna be
another 15 minutes
all right listen you know i hate the
canadians
i don't really have to canadians i hate
their [ __ ] fans you know that but you
also
hopefully know that i'm not gonna sit
here
like some liberal who jumped all over
trump and is now gonna
ignore the fact that joe biden literally
forgets what he's saying mid-sentence
and it's not gonna hold his feet to the
fire
i ain't gonna do the sports version of
that i gotta give it up
i got to give it up all right
two things all right the habs are a good
[ __ ] team and they got just as good a
chance as anybody who win in this
[ __ ] thing
i hate saying that but it's true
i really enjoyed watching them play last
night
and um
actually i had to set aside my hate for
their fans and be like wait a minute
bill
your team's out of it right
when whoever hoists the stanley cup you
know over their head lifts it
the season's gonna be over then what are
you gonna do
there's no more hockey so i am rooting
for seven games
in both of them i'll still you know i'm
still rooting for vegas
huh that dirty slimy town um
they don't even need to make ice on that
[ __ ] thing they're right on this
strip they should just [ __ ] be
skating on all the [ __ ]
sleeves of the though sorry anyway
it's a different time bill vegas is for
kids now
um
and jesus christ you know i saw a clip
from uh
the joe rogan experience podcast i don't
know if you've heard of it it's kind of
doing well
um um he had this guy on
i couldn't tell what he was you know
that's what i love about joe's
podcast if i don't know who the guest is
the person could be anywhere from an
mma fighter to a scientist
conspiracy theorist nutritionist you
have no he just
runs the gamut runs the gamut so i'm
sitting there look at this guy going all
right what is this guy is this guy a uh
is he a big wave surfer
is he uh martial artist
um is he uh
you know a life coach sounds like a life
coach okay he's going that way right
you know your brain your brain just your
brain is like a casting director it just
whatever it sees that's what it casts
the person has until you hear [ __ ]
coming out of their mouth and it's like
oh he's a police officer
you know somebody comes in with fat
fingers you're like all right they
they're a baker
[Music]
he's needing some dough and he decided
to do the podcast so anyways the guy
came in there
and he said that was talking about
gambling
in the suicide rate and he said
that that's why in vegas there's no
balconies
so people won't jump to their death and
uh
i never knew that i don't even know if
that's true but that's one of those
things you're like wow
at what point were they you know if that
is true
the amazing thing about that is at some
point
the hotels had balconies
so you're sitting there running a casino
and people keep jumping to their death
and you're just sitting there you know
talking to somebody the phone rings all
right hang on i got a phone call hello
again
okay is it was it on the lobby side
where people could see it
all right okay it's in back all right
relax relax
this kind of thing happens all the time
just you know hose them off
into the you know right up to the
threshold there try to try to get it
on circus circus's property
okay is there anybody else there yet
okay well turn on the hose
now all right i'll talk to you later
right then he gets off the phone he
looks at the other mob guys it's like
you know we got to get some locks on
those doors or the next one we built it
just
it just can't have any balconies right
or maybe the mob didn't give a [ __ ]
because you can't sue them up
you can sue a corporation but anyway
um so two things the the montreal
canadiens are a good goddamn team they
got just as good a chance as [ __ ]
anybody
because the islanders came in and
[ __ ]
hit tampa right in the [ __ ] chops
game one tampa comes back
goes oh yeah you think so
huh you [ __ ] animals on long island
think you're gonna hoist the first one
since 83 i don't think so right they
[ __ ] come in
[ __ ] gave them the business right
right up to [ __ ]
face washes after the final seconds
ticked off
one of the guys got thrown down on the
ice possibly injured i don't know
i don't know who right all i know is if
i ever get a hair system
i want it modeled after that number 14
on the [ __ ] tampa bay
lightning i got to tell you something he
he almost got into a fight and the refs
[ __ ] jumped into it like we were on
the real housewives because they never
let him fight
right jumps in the middle of it so then
number 14 goes to the [ __ ] penalty
box before he puts his helmet on he just
gives
that lion's mane a little shake huh just
for the ladies who are watching
oh man that hurt my me and my bald
freckled head i was like god damn it
that [ __ ] guy is does he even
understand how blessed he is
um so anyway i think these are actually
two really great series where everybody
you know
a lot of people uh i don't know if it's
called the east anymore i have no idea
what the the covid [ __ ] conference is
now
um i know people trying oh no tampa bay
is gonna [ __ ] handle the island is no
problem well we'll see because tonight
they play again
but uh um i'm really enjoying
everything that's going on and i'm
already like all right whatever if the
canadians win it
you know what am i am i going to be that
[ __ ] guy who's then going to ruin
this summer
because some team that's already [ __ ]
30 stanley cups in front of us won
another one i don't give a [ __ ]
so i'm just gonna enjoy that all right
so there you go there you go you pocket
squared [ __ ] in montreal i gave it up
to you you got a good [ __ ] team you
should be very happy i'm sure you are
um just try to be a little less racist
okay before you [ __ ] attack america
again
a bunch of animals up there um
that's what i always loved about that
michael moore [ __ ] documentary
was it bowling for columbine where he
made canada look like
and just you know you go up there and
everybody just you know would you like a
shot of syrup
everybody's just so friendly um
all right plowing ahead here um
so yeah i said two things the canadians
are a good goddamn team
and secondly kamala harris is gonna be
your first [ __ ]
female president really quickly
jesus christ
we have just been on we have been on a
[ __ ] tear
the last one two three four five
presidents
you know ever since george bush senior
right
that guy was like the last class act
that's kind of been there
i feel because you know he could have
gone in you know
after after we you know we defeated
saddam and kuwait he could have gone in
you know to baghdad and he was he he
played by the rules
he was like you know what this isn't
what we said we were going to do over
here
we need some sort of [ __ ] something
or other to go in there we don't have it
so when so we stop
that's what the [ __ ] he did right then
the next guy comes in
dick hanging out of his [ __ ] pants
for eight years
you know just [ __ ] like i don't know
what
bomb the country to get [ __ ] the
[ __ ] press away from him
okay and then the next one we get this
[ __ ]
guy hey i can't can't even [ __ ]
deliver a speech
coalition of the willing which was like
his idea in like rhode island
gets us into a 20-year [ __ ]
never-ending war that bankrupts the
country
then the next guy comes in says he's
hope and starts drone bombing weddings
and then he got [ __ ] trump he comes
in like you know
those neo-nazis say you know they i can
see their side of this [ __ ]
story and then we got forgetful freddie
i don't know what we're doing
i kind of feel like with bill clinton
actually you know what i did a movie
about this with gary hart when they went
into gary hart's personal life
and he had to answer for his
infidelities and all that [ __ ] all of a
sudden
once the mainstream press started acting
like
this is what i learned on that movie um
that that was the first time the
mainstream press started acting like
the national enquirer and ever since
then i think
that what they go for is they just go
from marrow
with these people that are running for
president and they try to dig up every
[ __ ] thing that they ever did
wrong and embarrass them and literally
ruin their families and i think anybody
who's like a decent human being who's
like i don't want to put my family
through that is kind of [ __ ]
backing off like i i don't think i want
to go for the [ __ ] brass ring of the
president's
presidency because it just seems weird
to me
that like i mean maybe they all of them
were always like that
and the press didn't just dig that deep
so maybe the press to just sort of back
off and just
understand that people are inherently
flawed and we all
made mistakes myself included
everybody's your human best what's so
dumb about people going
back into somebody's twitter account
let's go back to see if this person ever
made a mistake
i found one stupid
so anyway um oh jesus christ
oh billy bake sale um
was sitting in the car yesterday and my
jeans were like
digging into my [ __ ] waist and i was
like all right this ends now
all right this [ __ ] ends now so last
night
um this is what i did i actually had my
slice of cake earlier in the morning
i'm not throwing out the cake all right
what happened was i had a surprise party
that my
unbelievable wife got for me if you
haven't been listening to the podcast
and then somebody ordered this delicious
cake but it was from another restaurant
so because of covid they couldn't cut
the [ __ ] thing up
so we took it home and there it sat and
i sat across from it and i [ __ ]
basically ate three quarters of a
three-layer chocolate cake with
yellow cake with chocolate frosting i
enjoyed every [ __ ] bite as i did it
and then afterwards i would have like
heartburn because i was i was making i
was
taking like fred flintstone cuts out of
the thing
um literally the reason i had to quit
drinking is why i can't have a whole
cake sitting in front of me
because i i just look at it not much
like i gotta have it man i look at it
like a challenge
i bet i can finish that before it goes
stale
i used to look at bottles of bourbon i
bet i can finish that in three nights
third a third or third a little more
than the third right 33
33 34 i can do it
right so um last night
i went on a uh i stopped eating at five
o'clock
could have ate a little better but you
know i'm easing into this and then i
went for a nice walk
an old man walk listen to some music and
all of that
crushed some waters before i went to bed
got a nice night's sleep and i'm just
going to be doing that because i am not
going to be
uh billy fat tits when i do my [ __ ]
show in vegas
all right nobody wants to sit in 110
degree
heat and look at an overweight bald
ginger
okay and i respect that see that's the
difference between me
and these so-called feminists who are
really just a bunch of people who don't
want to go to the gym
you know they just want to show up after
eating cake and have everybody's got to
sit there and look at it
see i actually put myself in the
position i have empathy
i'm progressive i'm thinking about you
guys
you don't want me coming out there with
my [ __ ] you know you know you get so
fat like your [ __ ] belly button just
becomes like a horizontal line
you know just another roll of fat like
it's just literally
your your navel is never gonna see the
light of day again
i i can't do that i can't do it to
myself
i can't do it to america so
uh i'm on it right now i'm on it right
now i woke up this morning
and i made uh i made this tofu spinach
and pesto scramble
i don't know oh [ __ ] eating tofu for
you what are you going to suck a [ __ ]
now or you know
you know that [ __ ] actually causes
cancer
it all causes cancer all right
but some of that cancer causing poison
that is now our food supply
because the people in the food industry
are not held to the same standards
as a stand-up comedian telling a joke in
a strip mall
huh think about that one i got a bigger
chance of getting in trouble telling
jokes on that [ __ ] vegas strip
that somebody who runs a company that
poisons the entire [ __ ] food supply
they're not getting in trouble
they're throwing their merch money at
all of these [ __ ] fumbling stumbling
bumbling [ __ ] presidents we've just
had um
anyway uh so that's it
i am going to uh i'm drinking waters
i'm eating right i'm staying away from
all the bad food i'm going for [ __ ]
walks
and i think i'm gonna do what usually
happens the first five days you do a
nice
you do a nice damage to your gut
right but then by after the fifth day
about the first week your body starts to
adjust like oh
oh is this what we're doing is this what
we're doing
and that's why i i accidentally stumbled
onto something
i called it stomach confusion you know
they had you know they have muscle
confusion
where it's like you do all these
exercises and after a while your body
just gets used to it you don't get any
gain so you got to throw in some new
exercises and your muscles are evidently
like i can't figure it out man
and you get bigger i do the same thing
you know either thing like you just eat
well for like you know five days and
then you just have something you just
eat like [ __ ]
and your body's like what the [ __ ] is
this i thought we were eating right and
then the next day
the next day you eat well and your
body's
oh god oh thank god thank god you know
it's like a a a a physically abusive
relationship you know the other person
after a while
you know a good day to them as they
don't get smacked in their head
and i know right now all the broads are
listening to this putting
the only abusive relationship that there
is
physically is the male
hurting the female okay no one ever
stops to think what about a younger
brother
to an older brother that is just
inherently a physically abusive
relationship
and a good day for me was if i could
walk down the hall
past my older brother and not get
[ __ ] punched in the [ __ ]
shoulder slapped in the the worst was
when it wasn't the [ __ ] at least the
shoulder you saw coming
the worst was when you walked past him
you're like oh [ __ ] i think i got it
then you get that smack on the back of
the head
that made your teeth come together and
your eyes closed
and would make you so mad that in that
split second as you turned around you
thought you could beat up your older
brother
you know before you were quickly slammed
into the wall
i don't know what i'm talking about
right now i'm like joe biden what the
[ __ ] was my train of thought here
maybe i should be president
um
i mean dude i just saw clip of the guy
he literally just tapped out
anybody knows me you know knows that i
get things done and when i want to get
things done i uh
yeah whatever
just like wow wow
i think the only reason why liberals are
going to get on him
is because they want to see the first
woman president
not because this guy doesn't seem to
have the mental capacity
to be our leader right now they're gonna
want it for the narrative
rather than for the right reason of the
vice president
still has his of sound mind
what does this say what does this say
for women
uh it's a weird time people it's a weird
time and i'm a weird guy so i mean i
think i'm
i think i'm doing all right during this
weird time hey um
today was is the first day of summer
vacation for the kids in my
house and um i had such a great time
just waking up not having to drive my
daughter to school
and just being able to chill out and
felt like saturday
and i came downstairs and i made
everybody some scrambled egg and some
toast
you know did all the dishes wipe down
the counter and then i made my little
tofu
pesto thing did those dishes made sure
the [ __ ] kitchen was like immaculate
and all of that i can't even tell you
how much i love doing that
you know as much as i miss doing
stand-up
in front of live crowds and stuff like
that uh i don't miss doing the road
being away from them
um and what's
the only good thing you know one you
know there's been some positives
about the whole pandemic you know zoom
meetings
as much as people hate those things
isn't it nice to just the second it's
over
you're home you know
isn't it nice that you know you can do
the letterman thing and only have to
dress
nice from the waist up and the bottom
you can have like sweatpants on
you know that was nice but the other
thing is i actually got to live the life
of a local comic like there's definitely
been some times
especially the last 20 years watching
like what the sports teams in boston did
and all those championship parades and i
never went to any of them
um i did go to game two
of the 2004 world series i did go
to uh the
first time the patriots won the super
bowl i went to that one
and um
the bruins i did go to the bruins when
they came back against the maple leafs
uh i did see a few of those things but
there was definitely times when i was
thinking like you know what would have
been cool what if i was just one of
those guys
comics that never left boston i just
stayed there
and i made my money and you know the
worst
gig i would have i'd have to drive all
the way out to springfield and back in
one night but then the next day i'd be
there
you know there's something to be said
for that
and uh it's a great life
and i'm telling you i keep telling you
guys to watch this
it's the most important life lesson i
think i've seen in a while was that
marvin hagler response
when sugar ray leonard wanted the
rematch
and sugar kept ray leonard was kept
fighting
was addicted to the ring and all of that
but if you know his backstory you
understand why he was doing that so
but um just marvin hagler
his response
when sugar ray leonard sent that guy
over at the party or something said hey
sugar ray will give you a rematch she'll
make a ton of money let's do it what do
you say
and he said uh tell sugar to get a life
that's amazing you know
not now i'm not coming down on sugar ray
leonard because of you know
the stuff that happened because i don't
want to ruin it but like you could see
like what happened to that guy is just
the worst thing ever
and then like the ring became like his
um place where he actually felt like he
was in control but marvin hagler didn't
know his backstory so
but what i'm taking out of that is that
life lesson
of uh having a life outside of your
career
is the greatest for like happiness it's
just the greatest [ __ ] thing you
could ever do
so um no jesus christ i have to
i have to stop going to therapy because
this podcast has just become it's slowly
turning into
guys just try to [ __ ] do what you
want to do in life and be nice to people
all right let's do the um let's do some
reads here
i mean who would have thought i'd say
something like that after comple i
complimented the [ __ ]
montreal canadiens and then just went
into that syrupy [ __ ] all right all
birds everybody all the [ __ ] flappers
all birds
you know it's really getting warm up and
we're starting to feel more hopeful
about the rest of the year
it's time to get out there with all
birds
lace up and feel good with all birds
and they're sustainably made tree runner
shoes these shoes fascinate me
okay and i'm loving these companies
they're actually coming out
and they're they're addressing the fact
that what we're doing to the environment
myself included okay
listen to these things perfect fit style
support and made from
natural materials what's not to love all
birds are not just your average everyday
shoes but they will literally be your
favorite shoes to wear
every day once you get your hands on
these tree runners
these shoes are unbelievably comfortable
and light on your feet
i love that they're made sustainably i
love how they wrote that for me i
already said it naturally
um so look at even my statements are
organic in this copy
uh they are the most eco-friendly shoes
in the game made from sustainably
natural
sustainable natural materials that feel
light on your feet and are better for
the planet the tree runners are
breathable machine washable and made
with responsibly source eucalyptus
tree fiber sugar cane based sweet foam
tm midsoles made from the first carbon
negative eva resin whatever the [ __ ]
that means
packaging made from 90 recycled
cardboard
that's a shoebox shopping bag and mailer
all in one
has made dedic has been dedicated to
reducing environmental impact
since day one they're dedicated to it uh
from operations to productions they
treat the planet like a key
stakeholder holder in the company
certified as a public benefit
corporation keep things light and breezy
with the all birds tree runner
discover your perfect pair at
allbirds.com
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s dot-com
you know something everybody's trashing
these younger kids and generations
millennials generation z and all that
these are the kids that are going to
[ __ ] if anybody's going to turn
around it's going to be them
all right people from my generation and
on we're we're too buried in the lie
you know by dig made of plastic use it
it breaks throw it out don't get
fixed you know
planter will be dead won't die before i
do
that dumb [ __ ] so good for these young
kids i like what the the
the youth is doing and uh i can't stand
old people that all they do is [ __ ] on
younger people i can't tease them a
little bit you know
nobody's above a teasing you know unless
you're a white
female feminist
then everything is just precious all
right you know because their lives are
so difficult
uh roman everybody roman
most guys have tried different ways to
last longer but thinking about baseball
doesn't always work
what about rubbing one out right before
the folks at roman
and online men's health company are
changing the game with roman
swipes the secret to longer lasting sex
uh yeah this is good too because it
numbs up your dick a little bit because
if you rub one out right beforehand
if you're in a pinch you're like [ __ ] i
feel like i'm gonna bust you know before
it even happens you rub one out real
quick you know you got a little friction
burn on you
you know and then it's not as
pleasurable for you you know you got a
rug burnt you got a thumb burn
on the top of your shaft there all right
the folks they told me to improvise in
this uh the
the folks at roman and online men men's
men's health company are changing the
game with roman swipes the secret to
longer-lasting sex
um let's see here roman swipes are
clinically proven
way a pro clinically proven way to last
longer in bed oh i guess one of the ways
of lasting longer is saying the pledges
of pledge of allegiance in your head
don't do that because then you'll start
associating patriotism with getting some
right next thing you know you're at a
ball game and you wear sweatpants and
let's just say your hand's not the only
thing saluting the glow glory
uh roman swipes our clinically proven
way to last longer in bed that punchline
was way too long they're effective
easy to use and fast acting but don't
require a prescription
anytime you run out of breath in the
punch line you
need to trim the fat roman can ship
swipes to you discreet
he's got the dick wipes man that's not
gonna happen
unmarked cop [ __ ] his pants unmarked
packaging and each swipes
packet is small enough to hide in your
wallet for whenever you need it
uh swipes are great they will not
transfer to your partner
all right so her hoo-ha or is a-hole
whatever you're into
it's not to get numbed up swipes are
great
and they will not or somebody's mouth
whatever's on the other side of that
glory hole i'm not judging
swipes are great they will not transfer
to your part partner so
you can last longer without worrying
they're super easy to use
you just take it out you look for your
dick you put it on your dick you act
like you wash it and skillet
just take the swipes out of the packet
swipe it on and let it dry and you're
good to go that's it
call to action mandatory must read
verbatim all right relax
ah all right go to get roman.com
and get ten dollars off your first order
of swipes plus free
two-day shipping that's getroman.com
for ten dollars off your first order of
swipes
uh plus free two-day shipping and roman
is spelt r-o-m-a-n
bro man
numb your dick it'll do the trick that's
what i would say
um if i was running their ad campaign
which i'm not all right so that's it all
right i gotta go downstairs and do my
band workout
freckled tits pasty stomach
hanging over his belt you know this is
when you know you're fat when your belt
buckle is heating up from the back side
of your stomach
of your belly when you sit down in the
car
um when you drive with the air
conditioning on full blast
even at night um it's probably a good
idea that you maybe need to drop some
weight
you know when you're getting undressed
at night
and and your wife sees the side of your
your [ __ ]
your hips there and she goes what
happened to you
did you get into a fight no
that was just me being too stubborn to
move up a notch on the belt
that's what those red welts are about um
all right
whatever see this right here this is
called fat shaming
i'm my own corner man i'm fat shaving
myself
all right there billy cupcake hey billy
sprinkles
hey old ice cream scoop [ __ ] lay off
the sherbet will you
i've actually uh i don't think i've ever
tried more than a mouth and a half full
of sherbet
in my life i eat it i'm like god damn
that is too [ __ ] tangy and it doesn't
give me the sugar right
rush [ __ ] this [ __ ] and you know what
maybe that was my big mistake let's look
this up right before i get out of here
is sherbert healthy
is sherbert
healthy most sherbets and sorbets
hmm sorbets soybe
have about the same number of cal
calories as light or low-fat or non-fat
ice cream
or frozen yogurt but what they lack in
fat they make up for in
sugar which in my opinion
makes them no healthier who the [ __ ]
wrote that
they wrote it june 9 2010 they just
dropped
the mic the scoop on low-fat frozen
treats learn the difference between
light ice cream sherbet sober i don't
want to read all of this
oh jesus christ it's written by
a woman named joy so tell me she's going
to get to the point quickly
and to to further elaborate uh joy could
you come up here
every guy's head in the room oh [ __ ]
it looks like we're not getting a lunch
today looks like we're working through
lunch all right
okay everybody that's the podcast
you know there's no joy in listening to
somebody named joy describe something
stop name-shaming uh please listen to
the music and then there's a bonus
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast
uh have a great weekend you [ __ ] enjoy
the hockey
i'm still pulling for the vegas knights
but i goddamn it man
i'll tell you if you're in las vegas
right now you have to be [ __ ] staring
into your crack pipe being like what in
the [ __ ]
i thought we'd be up two games to none
as you're crawling around that motel rug
looking for a nugget another nugget
sorry all right that's it i'll talk to
you guys on monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the monday morning podcast
for monday june 17th 2013. you hear what
i added something there
i usually just say it's the monday
morning podcast and i went it is
the monday morning podcast as if to
suggest that i'm even more impressed
with myself this week than i usually am
how you guys doing how's your monday
yeah did you have a bad one
oh it's okay because there's always
tuesday
what'd you guys do if i actually wrote a
show tune about tuesday it was a blatant
ripoff of annie
you know you know i could actually play
any when i was younger when i was 12
i could have played annie
[Laughter]
oh you know how sad and [ __ ] true
that is
i really could have you know 12 my voice
still hadn't changed
i had this big stupid [ __ ] you know
you know i was in getting into metal
music i tried to grow my hair long but
it just
it was too thick back in the day still
wish it was thick
but we just [ __ ] grow out into like
an afro i just look like
an extra on like welcome back carter you
know which is [ __ ]
which would have been cool in the late
70s you know i missed my [ __ ]
wheelhouse by like
i swear to god maybe six seven years
if i had been born instead of 1968 if
i'd
been born in 1962 but then you know what
i would have been i'd be 51 right now
you know i would have started podcasting
late in the game
you know being all grumpy uh you know
when i was a kid you had to get a job on
radio um
anyways if somebody told me uh a funny
joke
that they had in uh the onion i don't
know if you guys read that that uh that
periodical
whatever the [ __ ] you call it newspaper
um
faux news is that what it's called i
don't [ __ ] know but they had
something whether it was somebody
sitting in front of a laptop i guess
with an anger anguished look on their
face
i haven't seen it but it says uh
something over 250 000 podcasters stress
trying to find guests for their podcast
this week
you know what that made me feel good
that made me feel really good because uh
i don't have any guests on my [ __ ]
podcast rarely do i have guests and
that's the [ __ ] main reason because i
don't want to have to sit
there and try to work with other people
and their schedules and that type of
[ __ ] and [ __ ] you know
i don't want to interview my friends so
what what is your middle name i don't
want to do that and then you know
they [ __ ] book [ __ ] and then they
cancel on you and then you're struggling
for a guest and then you have somebody
in there and you're like wow i wanted
this person to realize that
they weren't my first choice you know
speaking of which that reminds me i have
to get back to jay moore i've been going
in and out on the war
on the war going in and out on the road
why'd i say the war
because i was just reading a bunch of
international [ __ ] i think
and uh yeah he sent me a very flippant
text message
that i intend on addressing you know
classic east coast guy he just can't ask
you to be on the podcast he has to put
you on the [ __ ] defensive
you know so i'm gonna call him today
try to set up a time to do his podcast
and
and and we'll [ __ ] discuss his
flippant
[ __ ] text message to me which i did
not appreciate
all right see that jay i'm [ __ ] i'm
cross-pollinating here right
[ __ ] guy texting me he's texting me
he comes at me with this [ __ ] tone
like i owe him money
you know where is that [ __ ] text
message
he writes this [ __ ] like gathering
uh i gather by hearing you on other
people's podcast you're back in town
because i told him a few weeks ago he
said can you do my podcast i go no i'm
out of town
and then i was i went over to burke
christie's house i'll give you the whole
[ __ ] soap opera
because i go over burke christchurch
because i'm trying to get him on our all
things comedy podcast network
right so i'm shooting the [ __ ] over i'm
pitching the [ __ ] network to burke
crusher
and uh he goes well there's my podcast
shouldn't do but
[ __ ] it let's do a podcast so that's
what happened
so then jay gets his tears me on bert
this is what i'm guessing
here's me on bert's and he's like i
thought this guy said he's out of town
now you get his [ __ ] panties
all in a jersey bunch and then he sends
me this [ __ ] thing well i gather
you're in town
let me tell you something j morris jay
to the [ __ ] moors
okay i am not under any contract with
you
or anybody else in this podcast world
you understand me i am a free man
and i will [ __ ] podcast with whoever
the [ __ ] i want to
whenever i want to young man
that being said i'm going to try to do
jay's podcast this week
oh he's so sensitive
i love you jaymore all right
okay continuing on
speaking of [ __ ] wars because maybe
i'll start having a war with uh
jay moore be good it'll be good for both
our podcasts
um speaking of that [ __ ] not like i'm
gonna this i'm just all bullshitting
okay before you guys
[ __ ] go epic epic [ __ ] uh
something something twitter knockout
whatever the [ __ ] you
you know that's all i'm trying to say i
don't [ __ ] know what anything's
called
anyways i was on uh i was reading the
news today
as i do i got one of those ipad minis
for my birthday
so now what i do is i sit out on my
front porch like a [ __ ] old man in a
rocking chair
and you know that's something i was
fighting
fighting how great it felt to sit on a
front porch
sitting on a rocking chair reading the
21st century's newspaper you know
i don't have the paper in my hand and
there's not some little kid that comes
in hey mister
right throws the thing over the [ __ ]
wall
and i'm hey thanks thanks a lot there
johnny appleseed right
i give him a nickel and he goes oh
thanks mister he goes down and buys like
[ __ ] 80 pieces of
candy like you could back in the day
right down to the penny arcade
you know some guy down there with the
[ __ ] derby on
beating you with a cane um
i was fighting that feeling just sitting
out there i'm telling you right now
just [ __ ] give in to being an old
[ __ ] like me
sit out on a front porch if you don't
have one use your neighbors
right he's at work [ __ ] him that's his
fault for having a job you're in between
jobs
nobody's using his porch right
technically
that's not even his porch at least the
land isn't
that belongs to the air court what a
[ __ ]
uh the apache depending on where the
hell you live
that's not his [ __ ] land
what because a piece of paper says it is
i don't [ __ ] know so i'm sitting out
there on on
on my front porch on my rocking chair
and i was just reading about uh i'm
trying to figure out why
we are arming the rebels in syria
right and why russia is arming
the dude in power there that assad guy
whatever the [ __ ] his name is right
i can't figure out i'm trying to figure
out what both sides have to gain
you know was that president cool with us
and he was giving us whatever he wanted
and now he's not so we're like [ __ ] him
we're gonna help the
[ __ ] rebels i i have no idea
i [ __ ] uh scoured the internet for
like at least three minutes before i did
this podcast that i could not find
one [ __ ] reason why we were doing it
or why russia was doing what they were
doing
now russia is saying that the reason why
they they actually gave a reason they
said the reason why they are backing
the dude in power in syria is because
the syrian rebels
kill uh syrian soldiers and then eat
their hearts in front of the locals
and if that doesn't sound like a bunch
of [ __ ] i i don't know what is
so that's his justification he goes well
you know they're [ __ ] sitting there
uh
eating the entrails like licorice you
know we don't want to be a part of that
and uh but as far as i can tell we
haven't said why we're backing them
i don't know because they want democracy
which is what we always say but then
usually it's there's something else we
want there
you know something in their gift shop
that we got our eye on so i have no idea
so i'm going to pay attention to it you
know what i'm actually thinking i'm just
thinking
back this is just like uh we're just
making money
i think that that's what this meeting is
about northern ireland
right and we're like you the u.s is just
like well listen
we don't manufacture anything in our
country every more anymore everything's
[ __ ] left
you know with any luck we can [ __ ]
legalize weed we'll finally have
something to export again
so basically we're not making any
[ __ ] money and russia's just like oh
yeah you know we're [ __ ] uh
we got a big [ __ ] storm over here too
it's all right we'll arm this side you
want them not starting they kind of blow
each other up and uh we make a little
money what do you think sound good
all right let's make some money
on two on two ready break and then they
walk out
then that's it so anyways those rich
[ __ ] who run the world i guess are in
northern uh ireland this week
and there's no protesters there's like 2
000 protesters
you know i don't know as much as i [ __ ]
i don't think i'd ever go to a protest
it's just so much work you got to make
that sign
you know and then not another big thing
is you got to be informed
you know you know you're informed as a
protester they don't show your interview
on tv
they always show the biggest [ __ ]
wing nut at those things
you know half a titty out face [ __ ]
painted you know
hey man like it ain't right man
that [ __ ] hatchet dude i don't know
sorry this podcast
this podcast is all over the place but
you know what i have been all over the
place
i had another wonderful quick tour i did
uh
st louis cleveland ohio
and uh in buffalo new york and
um i gotta tell you i spent way too
little time
time in each city i uh i had a great
[ __ ] time in each and every one of
those
those places uh let's start with st
louis meet me and say louis louis
um i can't remember the name of the
[ __ ] place i'm playing everything's
named the pageant or the palace
i don't [ __ ] remember then my
my website takes it off the second it's
the day of the show it takes it off the
thing so now i don't even [ __ ] know
um anyways i performed in this wonderful
theater that i've been to before that
i'm actually gonna look up right now
because the owner's so [ __ ] cool and
i'm being a dick right now
let's see here saint louis
bill burr let's see what comes up here
bill burr bombs and st
louis what the [ __ ] is that now um
where the hell is it oh there it is the
pageant play the wonderful pageant
theater
and right up the street there they got
uh
they had all this cool old record store
which i never got into
they had a great pizza place and they
also had um they had this [ __ ] uh
this bowling alley slash cool bar
it was perfect it was just enough for
the old bowling alley thing
and not not like a whole hipster thing
with the bar and all it had was like
[ __ ] eight lanes it wasn't one of
those
places that has like 40 [ __ ] lanes so
me and jason lawhead went in there
killing time during the day and uh
we bowled one frame we were [ __ ]
horrific
i bowled and i think i bowled in 87
[Laughter]
you know i bowl once every five years by
the time i figure out how to get some so
i
bowl a straight ball of course but by
the time i figure out how to [ __ ] you
know
get back into that rhythm whatever the
[ __ ] it is that i'm doing wrong
my [ __ ] hacky swing there uh i'm
usually in the [ __ ]
sixth frame is that the right thing had
a beer they had a great time and i went
into their their uh
they have a they have a city park there
and i was thinking there's no [ __ ]
way
because they're like you know it's one
of the biggest parks in all the united
states and i'm like well i've been
through central park it's not gonna be
as big as that [ __ ]
this thing was [ __ ] huge highly
recommend it
if you don't like going to gyms i like
to work out outside just walk around and
that type of thing they got a [ __ ]
golf course there's a goddamn zoo in
there
right i'm walking around the outskirts
all of a sudden i'm looking at a [ __ ]
zebra
right i think it was i walked the whole
way around the outside it had to him in
at least four
four and a half five miles and uh
it was a great time then i went bowling
went out had a great show
what did we do that night oh then we
went upstairs to the rooftop bar
at like this the blue moon or whatever
the hell it is the moon tower hotel that
i was staying at
and uh went up there hung out met some
people after the show everything was
good and then there was these two
[ __ ] hilarious kids
who were like uh like 21 22 year
years old level drunk you know
this [ __ ] dude came up because
somebody yelled something about tim
tebow
during the show so he comes up to me
he's like yeah yeah
yeah the tim tebow stuff and i'm like
all right
all right cool man great glad you had a
good time three minutes later it comes
up to me
stuff all right man yeah i understand
you you already said that
you always say you're not driving are
you okay all right dude listen i'm gonna
be over here with some friends i gotta
go all right see you
sit down [ __ ] like half hour later
i'm coming back from taking a piss i
come back up and he's sitting down where
i was sitting
and he just good team oh
and uh he was such his buddy at this
point is trying
to get him up out of the chair and he
refuses to get up or help
and the other guy's too drunk to get him
out so it was like this [ __ ] keystone
cop [ __ ]
of this dude trying to drag his friend
out of the [ __ ] chair and we're all
sitting there meeting like four or five
other people
looking at them we finally just picked
our drinks up and
we went to another table and i think it
took him another 20 minutes to get him
out of the [ __ ] chair
um oh speaking of tim tebow everybody
huh
who's got the jesus freak we do
i love all these [ __ ] football fans who
would think that there's going to be
like a quarterback controversy um
now that we have tim tebow are you
forgetting that bill belichick is a
genius
okay and don't even talk to me telling
me he's a [ __ ] cheater all right i
didn't want to hear that [ __ ]
all right unless you're gonna [ __ ]
take down every other goddamn coach
including old mr [ __ ] twinkle toes up
there in seattle
uh pete carroll could you look any more
honest than [ __ ] pete carroll
right look at that guy he looks like
that [ __ ] mr green jean guy the next
door flanders
on [ __ ] uh the simpsons he doesn't
have the glasses but he has that vibe
flanders actually looks like william h
macy
with john lennon glasses um but i'm
saying pete carroll's vibe is that but
then you look at
the [ __ ] he did at usc and right before
the [ __ ] hit the fan and they were gonna
get suspended he [ __ ] takes off
and goes up to seattle hey and what was
pete carroll guilty of at usc doing
everything
everybody else does at that [ __ ]
level all right
so are you [ __ ] who call bill belichick
cheaters you're morons
all right that's the way the game is
played at that level
there's millions of dollars there's
yachts
there's [ __ ] the second that [ __ ] is
at stake
recognition legacy forget it all the
rules
are out the [ __ ] when they're all
being bent all right
so anyways this is why the patriots are
gonna are gonna uh if tim tebow
is ever gonna excel in the nfl it's
gonna be with the new england patriots
and i'll bring you one [ __ ] play i'll
leave you giving you i'll give you a
link to it
the reason for it was was back when doug
flutie was playing with us
not doug flutie who the [ __ ] was it who
did the pooch kick
wait wait a minute do i have that wrong
am i that old
what was that that famous [ __ ] play
where all of a sudden he [ __ ] came in
right that was with us
ah jesus christ i'm losing my [ __ ]
mind here
how old am i all right here we go
doug flutie pooch kick
right oh dramatic nfl music
there you go and he gets that was it was
with uh
jesus how [ __ ] long did he play i saw
doug
flutie when i had season tickets in 1989
where we had the little paul revere on
the side of the helmet 1980
[ __ ] nine and he graduated in like
84.
he'd already been oh that was before he
went to the cfl he'd been with chicago i
believe then he came with us
and uh oh jesus did i ever tell you that
[ __ ] story
i can't believe i'm gonna tell this
[ __ ] story um
okay when i came out what year this was
it was when doug flutie was playing
with the buffalo bills
and i remember you know that was first
right around then he had come out and
said that he had an autistic child
and he had he had the flutie flakes that
was to raise money for autism this great
thing
right and uh so
we're in the stands we're sitting in the
end zone
it's me bobby kelly and this buddy of
mine
uh one of my old drinking buddies from
back in the day
this is the guy i told you got he got
into the handshake fight with the elvis
impersonator
i have to tell you that one we were in
daisy buchanan it's a famous meat market
on newbury street in boston right
and uh you know everybody's in there
hammered right
everybody's listening to music and we're
[ __ ] whatever it's the middle of the
[ __ ] night
so basically every guy in there is
probably
50 to 60 percent on their way
to either getting laid or going home and
jerking off after a slice of pizza
that's right where the night is but
everybody still has hope
that they're going to be one of the guys
that gets [ __ ] laid all right
everything's going good music is playing
and all that [ __ ] all of a sudden
the entire you just feel this energy
towards the door like what the [ __ ]
going on you can feel this commotion
so we [ __ ] look over and there's this
guy
dressed up as elvis for no [ __ ]
apparent reason
it's like the middle of the summer you
know it wasn't the anniversary of his of
his death
i don't you know we weren't in vegas i
just this [ __ ] guy walks in dressed
like elvis
so all the whole energy of the [ __ ]
bar goes over there and
every [ __ ] chick in there wants to go
over and get their
per picture with the guy so this dude
basically
[ __ ] blocks the whole [ __ ] bar
even half the guys are laughing because
he's doing all the karate moves and [ __ ]
it was ridiculous it was funny
but also it was very passive aggressive
because all the [ __ ] went up to him
so and half the [ __ ] guys so
my buddy i g was pissed i didn't realize
he was pissed at him
so everybody's lining up shaking hands
with this elvis impersonator trying to
get that picture with them and blah blah
blah blah
so my buddy comes up to him he comes up
to him last
and he's [ __ ] he starts shaking his
head and when my buddy right before he
was gonna get into a fight i don't know
why he'd always be like looking up in
the air
like what's up dude what's going on huh
really really dude and he'd be like
looking like straight up in the air
which of course he always ended up
getting suckered but he was a big guy so
he's usually
able to make a comeback so he comes
walking up to this elvis impersonator
and he starts shaking his hand
and he's looking up in the end the guy's
sitting there going what's up maya
what's up
how you doing man like trying to be
elvis and he goes
he's like what's my buddy's like what's
up dude he goes hey
he's still shaking his hand he goes he
goes why can't you just be yourself
right and immediately the elvis guy is
trying to let go of my buddy's hand and
he won't let him go
so now that's kind of squeezing each
other's hand the guy's going come on man
come on let go
i got rings on man and my buddy just
keeps holding his hand he goes you know
he goes
i like roger clement he goes i like the
red sox you don't see me coming here
dressed like roger clemens
right now they're shaking [ __ ] hands
right and they're squeezing now he's
looking
this dude right through his stupid gold
frame glasses and the guy's going all
right
he drops the elvis [ __ ] going all right
let go of my hand and i'm [ __ ]
sitting there going oh my god
i'm gonna watch my buddy fight a [ __ ]
elvis impersonator
this is gonna be the greatest thing ever
and right then the [ __ ] bouncer steps
in
like you know when you're watching a
hockey game he like finally these two
guys are gonna fight
and then the [ __ ] ref comes in and
breaks it up and the whole crowd boos
that's basically what happens all right
so that's the background on this guy
so we're at this game he's a big guy
he's not the most quick-witted guy
doug flutie has now come back you know
he would play for boston college
he played for the you know bears than
the new england patriots so he's he's
one of our guys
but now he's playing for the buffalo
bills the game we're going to this is
now
i don't know like the [ __ ] uh like 97
98 or something
and um i think pete carroll was coaching
jesus bill get to the story
all right so every so fluties warming up
in the end zone so
now everybody's giving fluty [ __ ] even
though he's our guy but he's playing for
the other guys now so it's like some
johnny damon [ __ ] even though it wasn't
his fault but you know boston sports
fans were [ __ ]
so everybody's giving fluty [ __ ] they
yell okay kill the [ __ ]
hey floaty you're too short all these
short jokes or whatever
so my buddy wants to get one in
all right and we we have end zone seats
so we're we are sitting with a bunch of
[ __ ] animals so
everybody's killed the [ __ ] flutie
you're too short not today dougie
you know go back to canada you stake
right everybody giving them [ __ ] and
then my buddy
he wants to be part of it he chimes in
he kind of stutters
he just goes he goes hey hey hey flutie
i hope your kid dies
right dude the whole section just goes
oh and just sits down
it was that was one of the most
[ __ ] evil things but you gotta
understand
why it was funny to me was just because
i knew
i knew my buddy and i knew how [ __ ]
dumb he is and i know
that he just wanted to be a part of it
he's just one of those guys who doesn't
know where the line is
you know those guys we just go hey you
know you start making fun of this shirt
and they go yeah at least my mother
doesn't have breast cancer and you're
like jesus christ
how the [ __ ] do you go from a shirt to
breast cancer that's basically what he
did
and uh i remember what's says
bobby kelly was absolutely
[ __ ] speed was speechless
[ __ ] speechless it was one of the
few times i've ever seen bobby is every
bit as twisted
as i am i'll never forget that he was
[ __ ] oh wait a minute what am i
talking about i've told this story so
many times
i wasn't i was sitting up a section over
jesus christ jesus christ i've told this
story so many times i forgot no he was
sitting there over there i was
i was the next section over that's right
and then bobby came up to me at the end
of the
the game and told me it so wait who else
was [ __ ] over there
i can't remember i don't know how the
[ __ ] how did i even get on that [ __ ]
story
oh fluty that's right cheating okay
let's work our way back bill work your
way back
i don't know hang on is it time to do
some [ __ ] habit yeah 25 minutes in
here we go a little bit of advertising
this week everybody just a little bit
a little bit of advertising where the
[ __ ] is it
all right who's up first oh
hulu plus everybody you've tried
streaming hit shows on your pc on
hulu.com
um now it's time to start your free
trial of exclusive content in your
living room and on your mobile
devices on hulu plus with hulu plus you
get control to watch
thousands of shows wherever you want
whenever you want
use hulu plus on connected tvs game
consoles blu-ray
players roku apple tv pc or watch from
anywhere on your smartphone
or tablet on demand at all times and
with hulu plus
you can binge on full seasons watch your
favorite current shows
and even full series runs of classic tv
shows it's endless
um they've got community modern families
south park snl jimmy kimmel family guy
and more nothing but top shelf all the
shows you want to see
they got them in their catalog hulu plus
is only 7.99 per month but right now
they're offering an extended free trial
of hulu plus
that is only available to podcast
listeners take control
of your tv watching experience go to the
podcast page on billboard.com
and click on hulu plus banner for your
extended free trial or go to hulupus.com
bill again the hulu plus banner on the
podcast page at billboard.com or go to
hulupus.com
bill and e-voice everyone
e-voice is the reason you're going to
make more money in 2013.
unless you're some gold-digging [ __ ]
and you plan on divorcing your rich
husband
okay but for the rest of us common
people
e-voice is the reason that we're gonna
make more money in 2013.
when your customers call and you have
your own toll-free number professional
greeting dial by name directory and more
is that a sentence that's like a
fragment
oh when your customers call you'll have
your own
toll-free number professional greeting
dialed by name directory and more sorry
that's on me
uh you'll sound like a fortune 500
company and blow away your competitors
e-voice lets you give out one number
that rings wherever you are
the beach the bar doesn't matter you'll
sound like you're at the office
so this is a great way to start a
business while you're still at somebody
else's
working for somebody else you know what
i mean we get it bill
finish the copy okay you got to go to
evoice.com and use the promo code bill
evoice even takes all your evil all your
voicemails transcribes them and sends
them direct instantly to you
as a text or email so you can check your
voicemails before the meeting ends and
not even look rude
e-voice is only 10 bucks a month right
now listeners to my podcast can get a
free trial of e-voice for 30 days
stop what you're doing hit pause set up
your e-voiced free trial
and see what i'm talking about it's a
great way to support my podcast
and an easy way to make more money this
year go to evoice.com promo
code bill that's evoice dot com promo
code bill
or just go to the podcast page on
billboard.com and click
the e-voice banner right now okay
so have you been what have you been
watching you've been watching spurs heat
you've been watching uh bruins
blackhawks either way
couple of amazing series i blew it
yesterday i was traveling so i missed
the
san antonio game i'm obviously thrilled
that san antonio is up three games to
two going back to miami
you know now you know me i love the
celtics and anybody who plays the lakers
but um there's just a douchebag factor
to people down in miami where let's all
go to the game and wear white
you know and of course it's white you
know
that white white is the um hang on a
second
you know what white is like the that's
the color
that people who want to flaunt that
they're rich wear
have you noticed that like whenever they
do
like those uh those real housewives
stories
they always have some ridiculously
expensive car and it's always
it's always like like like pearl white
i don't know what it is about that they
love it out here in
uh in l.a all the growing up gaudy
[ __ ] people they [ __ ] all have
those white cars
i don't know why so when i look at those
people down in miami it's the same
[ __ ] thing
you know what are you showing off your
tan lines even when you're in the car
i don't understand it where i come from
you know you got to get a black car
you know some gangster-looking thing you
get some tinted windows on it
i don't [ __ ] know although i got to
tell you i was a big fan of milk trucks
back in the day and those are always
white
this podcast is just what the [ __ ] am i
talking about so i'm rooting for i'm
rooting for san antonio
i really you got to go for the underdog
here you know the big fundamental
the guy who cheated on that chick from
that [ __ ] show right
the other guy there the uh
the bald guy uh tony coach i don't [ __ ]
i don't watch hoop
i don't know what's going on um
why don't you stick with what you've
been watching bruins blackhawks
everybody
uh right now if you haven't been
watching the series is tied one game to
one
both went into overtime the first one
went into triple overtime
and uh two nights ago it was an overtime
win for the bruins it was kind of weird
because i felt like the bruins should
have won the first one and the hawk
should have won the second one
although i missed most of the uh
most of the second game because i was
performing in uh buffalo
but uh it's a classic man and the
blackhawks
they like the bruins man they're a
[ __ ] hockey team you know they got
their tough guys
i'd say they have more superstars with
hosa and patrick kane
but um they got their pest
and then they got their grinders man
they're a [ __ ] hockey team and um
i really invite you know i don't know i
i really
like the way they're playing no filthy
[ __ ] you know
i don't get mad at those those guys who
you know just doing [ __ ] to try to get
an edge but nobody's out there trying to
hurt anybody
none of that [ __ ] crap um it's just
been two great games and
they play again tonight pivotal [ __ ]
game pivotal [ __ ] game
um so we'll see we'll see how the bruins
come out i heard they came out real
sluggish in game two in the first period
and came out hitting in the second
um like i said i only came out after my
show i saw halfway
the last half of the third period and
then into the overtime but
um i watched every second of that first
one
um and i was i was trying to stay in
shape when i was on the road
so i watched the first three periods and
then the first two
overtimes i was on the elliptical i
basically i stayed on the elliptical
until there was an intermission and then
on the intermission i did push-ups and
dips and then coming out of the
intermission i did the whole [ __ ] did
the elliptical again for the next period
i was actually thinking like that's how
you should be watching sports instead of
sitting there eating [ __ ] nachos
and drinking beer right um
but uh i don't know what are you gonna
do i i gotta tell you the blackhawks
[ __ ] goalie man is unbelievable and
the exact way paella scored is i think
what we have to do the second it hits
your stick just put it on net because if
that guy gets a chance to square up on
you
he's just stopping everything the
goaltending is top-notch
original six that's all i'm going to say
i really don't have anything bad to say
about any of the blackhawks i [ __ ]
like all of them
and uh i'm hoping it goes seven and i
obviously hope
that we win but uh they're a great
[ __ ] team
so tune in and check it out all right
let's get to the uh let's get to the
[ __ ] um
the goddamn uh whatever questions for
the week uh
billy redface tour uh william i used to
live in uh north dakota
and have been to northern cities on your
tour if you are planning to drive
between gigs
the country is beautiful but the
distances are immense
wrap your brain around long drives six
to eight hours depending on how fast you
drive
uh i now live in chicago go blackhawks
yeah dude you gotta understand i've been
doing the road
hardcore since the late 90s so you know
i can do six hour drives in my sleep but
i'm also i'm taking a bus so it's not
gonna be a problem but
um i'm also beyond excited to do this
tour because
i have performed in boise i never did
that comedy club but i did do a college
up there it wasn't boise
state it was something else um
[Music]
so i i drove around a little bit but
i've never been to montana and i'm
basically gonna drive across that whole
state
i have done i've done like sioux falls
south dakota
and i've done like fargo north dakota
but i've never been to the western part
of the state so
i'm going to be loving life um when i'm
out there so i want to see
all those cool looking ranches i want to
see a couple of bison
i want to see the [ __ ] billboards
with before and after pictures about
people on meth
you know what i mean that's like a major
[ __ ] problem like
i bet you nobody i bet the walking dead
gets really low
ratings out in montana just because if
they just all they need to do is look
out their [ __ ] window right
to see that
[Laughter]
i'm googling right now montana meth
problem
they got meth project documentary
highlights
montana's meth problem npr npr was up
there
yes montana has a meth problem
in montana montana meth project
news about the montana meth project so
they got a project going on
let's read this one here yes montana has
a meth problem
do you guys really want to hear me read
out loud you probably don't
uh i heard that utah and colorado have a
similar situation but i don't know who
is the leader
um i get tired of arguing the point but
the facts don't support your post i'm
not going to present
evidence because it's clear it would not
matter
i guess he's defending montana i don't
[ __ ] know it's going to be a great
time
oh you know i never finished talking
about that tour that i just did the uh
i went to cleveland ohio
all right had a great time one of my
favorite people in this business nick
costas
owns uh pickwick and frolic slash the
hilarity's comedy club
and that's where i played from 2004
right on up
he used to headline me when i could only
draw half the [ __ ] room
and a half of those people would just go
in there because nick had such a great
restaurant upstairs in the martini bar
and everything
um and when nick bought in
to that part of the uh the city
you know there was nobody there like i
it was just crap you got to go in there
it's like a five-star restaurant
they got a live show with these these
dancing girls downstairs in a martini
bar and then he has this beautiful
showroom with a balcony
it's it's absolutely gorgeous place
and um so he built this thing when they
would
when cleveland was just after 5pm became
a ghost town
and you'd be in there you felt like you
were on the [ __ ] titanic except it
never sank right
you just on this luxury liner there was
you didn't have to leave you ate you had
this great meal
you did your show and then when you
walked out there was all these beautiful
women and this martini bar was the
self-sustaining unit this [ __ ] oasis
but the second the night ended the cop
would literally escort me out of the
place and would walk me over to my hotel
so i wouldn't get clubbed over the head
by a piece of pipe that was probably
laying right in the street
and uh he was the only game in town
especially on the block that he was on
and he was kind of like a third of the
way up the block so he's really hidden
and he was having a rough go of trying
to get the thing going
and uh over the years i watched like the
house of blues opened up across the
street
blah blah blah fast forward to now nine
years later
you know i'm in town i'm doing this
theater right down the street and i'm
like i gotta go see nick so i go over
there to go get
uh some dinner before the show
and i'm coming up the street and it's
just a mob scene
it's just like outdoor everybody's
outdoor cafes is this guy playing
acoustic guitar
like hired by this restaurant house of
blues is just line up the street
um he's just the greatest [ __ ] guy so
i went over there
i had dinner and then i went and i did
my show
i had a great time you know went out
took pictures
signed dvds and all that [ __ ] and then
we had the after party
over at his his martini bar because i
wanted to drive some business his way
and i want to thank everybody seriously
man it's no [ __ ] everybody came over
there if you spent one dollar over there
that's one of my great friends
uh in business and in life so i really
appreciate it and if you ever
seriously in the cleveland area you want
to see a great show just have a great
meal
go down to the uh that pickwick and
frolic room man that guy's the best nick
costa say hello tell him i said what's
up
so anyways back to the uh
back to the reads here where the [ __ ]
are they
i am the worst all right no subject on
this one bill your problem with
christianity
is that you are in the wrong church just
switch over to the episcop
episcopal or lutheran or something and
get baptized and all of a sudden you
will receive the holy spirit
which will bring you to a higher
spiritual level
with a literal connection to god
uh all right you know something
i'm sure every religion
has its uh has something to offer you
know what it is about episcopal or
lutheran is i'm lazy
i already know you can't teach an old
dog new tricks okay i know the prayers
and i know the songs from my [ __ ]
this would be like me moving to la and
not being a celtics fan anymore and
switching over to the clippers
you know not saying you well the
clippers are actually decent now so i
can't i'm not really insulting you but
uh
yeah tell me some more about the
episcopal and uh lutheran thing because
i actually
always enjoyed going to church as far as
i felt like it was
a reset thing every week to remind
yourself not to be a complete hunk of
[ __ ]
or at least try not to be for as long as
you could until the next mass
but i just never liked all the other
crap that was involved in it
um but as far as me receiving the holy
spirit which will bring me to a higher
spiritual level
and a literal connection to god like i
can really do that on my own
you know if i wanted to if i really
if i wasn't such a piece of [ __ ] if i
really just i
you know you don't really need to go
down there and do all the hola
selima that's all just you know rituals
and i bless the water and i throw it in
your face and now
the evil spirits are out of you it's but
it's complete horseshit you could splash
me with as much holy water as you want
to
if i don't give a [ __ ] and i want to go
out and just do
the water is not gonna like fix me you
know
oh bill stop being a [ __ ] swing by you
know what i'm gonna go to one
i'll go to lutheran episcopal's too hard
to say
um
i don't know man i get weirded out when
i go in those [ __ ] places and every
hey how are you glad you showed up and
everybody grab hands it just makes me
feel all douchey
um all right freedom bill please don't
talk about freedom when you are over
there
over where
well why don't you [ __ ] oh
okay here we go this guy's gonna trash
america all right bill please don't talk
about freedom
when you people over there don't have
the freedom to decide
whether you want half your dick cut off
or not the way women in africa don't
have the freedom to decide whether they
want half their vagina cut off or not
they don't cut off their vagina you
ignorant dumb [ __ ]
all you american [ __ ] americans do
is talk about freedom because you have
none
um you know what sir you sound as
ignorant as what you're making fun of so
congratulations
welcome to the quad sir when did i talk
about freedom
i don't even remember talking about that
sir you know half the [ __ ] i talk about
i'm just trying to fill up an hour here
all right americans
was that your best one did you have a
list can you come up with something a
little bit better
you know americans you're trashing all
the americans so you're basically
trashing this whole half of the
half of the uh the world you do realize
that these are the americas north
america and south america
all right and you're calling me a dumb
[ __ ] they don't they don't [ __ ] cut
off after vagina they remove the
clitoris there
you know how exactly do they do that
i don't want to know that's [ __ ]
disgusting um
what is he talking about all right the
guy every week i'm talking about bankers
how they got everybody by the balls
sir do you listen to this thing all
right we're just going to move on you
know what you are you're basically
that was the uh the email version of
that guy who kept saying tebow to me
all right my car is [ __ ]
hey billiam i'm a high school student in
arkansas
all right razorbacks sec and my car is
pure [ __ ]
the pain is blotchy dude this isn't pimp
my ride
what do you think i'm gonna do [ __ ]
go over there have somebody come and uh
put a flat screen tv in your trunk uh
the paint is blotchy and fading the
interior is [ __ ] the air conditioner
doesn't work and there's a ton of
stickers on the back from the previous
owner
it's actually embarrassing anytime a
person especially
girls see it so how do i get over my
shitty car
also your podcast has not only helped me
relieve the stress
from school but it gets me through class
if i'm having a slow day
all right what you got to do is you have
to embrace your shitty car
you know it takes a certain swagger
to drive a shitty car you got to have a
sense of humor about it
you know if somebody trashes your car
just uh just you know you can do one or
two things either agree with them or
just be like how dare you
how dare you trust that that right there
is a classic that's an original
condition
all right or whatever i don't know what
the [ __ ] to do
you can take the bumper stickers off you
know you could throw some rims on it
you know what [ __ ] that don't don't put
rims on a piece of [ __ ] car
this is the biggest thing that i would
say all right if you're trying to get a
lady
right you're in college everybody
understands you're going to be broke
what i would do
you got to make sure the inside of the
car is clean
spend some money get that [ __ ] steam
cleaned
and get some [ __ ] air fresheners so
it's it smells all right
all right you could probably take off
the bumper sticker
you can get a 99 [ __ ] paint job every
[ __ ] state you go to
there's some [ __ ] on tv talking about a
99 paint job
you know pick a dark color you know that
usually will uh i don't know maybe paint
over the other [ __ ] well i don't know
much about paint i have no idea
maybe you'll be all right what kind of
car is it sir if you could help me out
with what kind of car you have
uh maybe i could help you out i don't
know
listen i drove an 83 ford ranger
two-wheel drive
five-speed am fm [ __ ] rare just was a
mess
and i finally put a nice stereo in there
and somebody smashed the window
ripped up the [ __ ] plastic like
dashboard and yanked the radio out and i
didn't have room for another one i had
this gaping [ __ ] hole with wires
hanging out
and uh and i wasn't getting any [ __ ]
there you go sir you know what i've come
around to your side i see what the
problem is
um you know what i would go to campus
parties
and try to go back to her dorm room
just avoid the whole car thing the whole
car situation
or you know something if you meet a girl
that you really like just submit to it
and just say listen
i gotta i gotta tell you something
before we go to my car my car is
it's a mess and uh it's really
embarrassing i'm really
self-conscious about it but bob just own
up to it girls love that
because then that kicks into the
motherly thing they can oh and it's okay
i don't think it's that bad and next
thing you know they're blowing you
so they just make sure it smells okay
that's the biggest thing
about women when you're younger and you
don't have any [ __ ] money if you just
make a [ __ ]
effort you know have you
if you're going out just make sure in
case you get lucky
clean up your [ __ ] room don't have
dirty laundry laying all over the place
make the [ __ ] bed get a couple of
scented candles all that hacky [ __ ] you
know
and for the love of god when you get in
there do not have overhead lighting
there's nothing women hate more than
[ __ ] overhead lighting as
uh middle-aged guys like me is your
baldic you
really start to hate overhead lighting
[Laughter]
but when you know women they [ __ ]
hate overhead lighting
all right so if you have overhead
lighting go out and buy
invest in a [ __ ] just a just a
[ __ ] bedside reading lamp or whatever
and then buy some cool [ __ ] i know
this is hacky but just cool some cool
fabric if you can throw it over the top
gives it more of a [ __ ] soft light
little mood
makes you know what titties are out if
you got some skills you know
you [ __ ] round in second and the rest
is on you okay
there you go all right the royal family
everybody
um this one says bill i'm curious about
your feelings on the royal
wait i got to back up i remember the
first time i brought a girl back when i
was in new york
and i didn't i didn't have [ __ ] i had my
[ __ ] couch from my dad's dental
office in the early 70s floral pattern
made out of wood that like i swear to
god you could [ __ ] kill a village
you could club people to death with
these couches like it took like three
people to bring it in
um and all i had was the oh i had
overhead lighting i had a light bulb
with nothing even covering that and i
had this old fixture that you'd turn it
on it would make this
like you slapped somebody in the face
when you turned it when you turned it on
and uh we were just sitting there and
like i can't it was like we were sitting
next to the sun
and that was when i first learned about
overhead lighting and
you know i made my move and everything i
was like two minutes and she was just
like all right wait wait can we just
like just wait a second and she goes i
need to fix something
she went in and i had my bedroom door
was open what she did was she turned on
the light in there that was also
overhead lighting
but it was another room away and then
she went and she turned off the light
in the living room and guess what i did
the next day
i went out and i bought a [ __ ] lamp
[Laughter]
there you go that's my lamp story
everybody
okay uh the royal family bill uh i'm
curious about your feelings on the royal
family
and the brits occupation of northern
ireland looking forward to seeing you in
september at the chicago theater
go hawks uh bruins remind me of a bunch
of prince charles's on skates
no they don't you know i really hate
when [ __ ] people like those are two
great [ __ ] games
and then your team wins and then you
text me bro zuck
or suck it you know those [ __ ] morons
that's why you know i've kind of stopped
tweeting about sports on my twitter page
because
it literally it was turning into the
exact reason why i don't go
to a sports bar because of all just the
all day the whole day
you know that type of [ __ ] and it's
always the most unathletic
[ __ ] [ __ ] can't even talk about the
game just complete [ __ ] so
uh i don't know i kind of toned down the
twitter the twitter there
um my feelings on the royal family in
the brits occupation of
northeast ireland uh obviously i don't
think they should be there it's not
their [ __ ] place
you know i actually learned all that
[ __ ] about the whiskey now i've been
drinking jameson this whole [ __ ] time
which i guess is from northern ireland
so i guess that's the sellout whiskey if
you're in ireland
and you're supposed to be drinking
powers but i can't find powers anywhere
and jameson his marker did really well
that's like the pepsi of whiskey i guess
um i don't [ __ ] know should they be
there i don't i don't think so
i don't understand why they haven't left
yet
they've left pretty much everywhere else
they've gotten beaten back
pretty much everywhere else india hong
kong
rwanda the united states of america
they've been beaten back falkland
islands they held on in that one
you know what they like they like uh the
royal families like tiger woods
after his divorce you know lost a ton of
[ __ ]
but still has money you know
other than that i don't mind him i don't
mind that that prince guy
whatever his [ __ ] name is the blonde
guy
harry harry looks like a [ __ ] though
he does he's got that he's got bully
face i don't know if cause all those
freckles or whatever
but he just looks like the kind of kid
that would just [ __ ] punch you in the
side of the head for no reason
uh his older brother looks a little soft
though you know
probably artistic i don't know [ __ ]
about him to be honest with you
you guys seem to like them so god bless
you
continue continue to pay attention to
them aren't they like your kennedys
and there's so much inner [ __ ]
breeding going on that they all kind of
have the same face
just like the kennedys kennedy's all
easy did you see the [ __ ] teeth on
that family
um okay lost it to a famous guy
bill my name is jessica holy [ __ ] a lady
finally writes in i'm 20 and i live in
miami great i've already trashed miami
here
okay so about a year ago i was
vacationing
in dr is that dominican republic
uh i don't know and i met a famous
person and ended up sleeping with him
dominican republic i'm gonna guess it
was a baseball player
did you [ __ ] sammy sosa um
he goes he's not very famous in the u.s
oh okay only in latin america
all right ricky martin's gay
um oh is that one of those is that the
guy that j
lo was married to i don't [ __ ] know
all right let's let's plow ahead here
point of the story is that ever since
that night we've kept in touch and i've
already seen him three times since then
this is really interesting she goes i've
seen him every time he comes to miami
isn't this great being like a hot chick
you can like bang famous [ __ ] people
you know and just not be just be like
working at kinko's
but you're hot and you can like bang
somebody that you saw in a movie
you know as a guy you just we just don't
have that option
you know good looking guy you're working
at kentucky fried chicken do you think
you're gonna bang olivia wilde i don't
think so
um the last time i saw him was this past
april we usually go out to clubs while
he's here and i've even met some of his
famous friends
i'm just a regular girl so you can
imagine how infatuated i am with this
guy
i am infatuated with this story um
she goes he's the only person i've ever
slept with so you could imagine the
amount of emotion i've invested in this
please tell me you made him use a condom
with his around-the-world dick sorry
not trying to ruin the romance here just
throwing a little bit of reality
um i've always get i always get sad
because i know that things are probably
not going to work
out in my favor besides the fact that he
is famous
he also lives in a different country
than me he's 10 years older than me
and as a child well that's game set
match right there sweetheart i think you
got to protect your heart
nah either put him in a place mentally
where you're not going to develop
feelings and when he comes to town you
get to have a fun time
um but other than that when he leaves i
would try and find somebody
you know that at least lives in this
hemisphere i don't know but hey it's
your life
all right he goes i have hope that a
relationship she goes i hope
i that a relationship could happen
because i've been lucky enough to have
so much
to have so much has happened already in
addition he has plans to move to miami
soon
we talk once a month or every couple of
weeks through text
well listen he might just be stringing
you along
um so
i would be like look i'm starting to
develop feelings for you and uh
you know i kind of got to cut it off
here to protect myself but if you moved
miami then we can pick up where we left
off
sound good hola
all right i mean that's all that's halal
right
whatever she goes we talk once a month
or every couple of weeks through text
only thing is
i'm usually the one that takes the
initiative to text him or see him while
he's here
which really bugs me uh yeah you know
what i can't i don't even need to read
the rest of this
i'll blow through the rest at the same
time he always shows interest in me when
we spend time together remembers
everything yeah you might just be his
woman in that
in that town i hate to tell you she goes
should i hope for a relationship with
this guy given everything that's
happened already no you shouldn't
should i stop talking to him since i am
the one that takes initiative most of
the time
or should i be content with the
situation uh
yeah he's stringing you along he's
stringing you along
um i don't think he's a bad guy
but you're his uh you're his woman in
miami
so um sounds like you want more than
that
so as much as his glamorous life
is interesting to you in the end it
sounds like you're going to get hurt if
i had to guess
if i had to guess it sounds like you're
going to get hurt so i would uh
i would just end it you know
just stop texting the guy you know
that's what i would do just stop texting
them just be like hey you know when you
you when your
shiny watch come back to miami if i'm
not in a relationship you want to hang
out down at the ground round let's uh
let's [ __ ] do it
but other than that you know why don't
you [ __ ] uh
enjoy the world and the [ __ ] that it
has to offer
right i'm sorry i'm being a little crass
here but that's
basically that's basically the situation
all right
if i ever had a long i've tried the long
distance relationship thing it didn't
end up working out
uh you know i don't know so anyways
that's the podcast for this week
everybody
how far into this am i huh 55 minutes
55 minutes all right
well before i go i want to thank
everybody who came out to all my shows
in uh out there in buffalo
oh dude i didn't even talk about buffalo
i played this uh this symphony hall
beautiful beautiful symphony hall
unbelievable crowd and all of that
and um had a lot of people from toronto
came over
asking me when i'm going to be in canada
and the answer to that
is i hate that it's going to be next
march i know i know what the [ __ ]
uh it was supposed to be this summer but
i don't know we just felt like the
summer time it's always snowing up there
you can finally go outside why are you
going to sit inside and watch some red
[ __ ] like me on stage
when you can go out and go water skiing
or whatever the [ __ ] it is you do up
there
so and also just figured i'd have a
better chance on getting on
some radio stations if it was hockey
season be another angle to sell amazing
comedian first time tour in canada he's
a big hockey fan bruins fan he can come
in and hang with you when he
talks sports sort of a marketing thing i
was pushing for january and then we got
worried
about flights with the snow and all the
[ __ ] up there and uh
i know you're like what the [ __ ] but no
you can't run a string of dates together
flying into the middle of a [ __ ] storm
because you'll end up missing a date and
i don't want to deal with that so we've
decided on march
i'm going to hit all the hockey cities
and possibly a couple of more depending
on how ticket sales go
and i'm going to start doing these like
more of these mini tours
like the red face tour by the way
tickets are are selling
they're selling like hot tanks so um
what do i got here coming up uh yeah the
28th
through august 3rd no it's not 28 27 26
july 26 through august 3rd uh for those
of you who haven't been listening this
past week i'm going to be hitting
doing shows in the states of idaho
montana south dakota
kansas uh colorado
western texas and uh i got a private
show
in uh new mexico so um
i got that whole tour set up i'm working
on a european tour and so far i know
we got london we got something in
scotland and
amsterdam and i imagine i'm going to do
all the scandinavian countries
and then probably all the way over into
helsinki
do i'll do ireland i'm hoping to do
ireland scotland
uh england amsterdam
and then hit copenhagen oslo stockholm
and helsinki
um that's what i would love to do and
then
i don't know i'm either gonna go after i
do all that
and i make some money or whatever i'm
gonna [ __ ] either go down to italy
and eat like a
[ __ ] pig or i'm gonna go to paris
uh go over to france i'm going to go to
like francis something like because i
i took french i tried french for a long
time when i was in uh high school
and i was always into the tour de france
i'd always watch
uh the tennis roland garros um
i don't know i was a big world war ii
buff there for a minute
and then you know all the d-day stuff
there's so much
there's so much that i want to see in
france alone
you know i want to see the beaches of
normandy i want to go to the memorial
cemetery
i want to go to the french open i want
to go to the tour de france i want to go
to paris
you know i want to ride a bike in paris
why not right head and twinkle toes
put on a [ __ ] beret big loaf of
french bread coming out of my backpack
you know wearing those pants that don't
fit down to my [ __ ] ankles and a
striped shirt on grow a little stupid
mustache
why not right and then i want to go over
to [ __ ] uh
italy these are all dreams of mine i
want to go to italy
and i want to somehow learn enough
italian and start people over there
arguing about who makes the better
whatever the dishes
and then let me be the judge and then i
sit there and eat like a [ __ ] king
i want to do that i want to go to
belgium and drink some booze
i i ran into somebody on the road told
me they got trapped over in belgium one
time because it was snowing
you know and and they just sat there
drinking beer all night
and uh stepping outside every once in a
while just looking at this beautiful
snow
in this city and i literally could see
it i was just like i want to [ __ ] do
that so
um i don't know trying to expand the
horizons here people
and next year so next year i got the
canadian tour and then also i'm gonna
try and do a tour of uh i'm gonna try to
tour
all of australia which would be perth
all the way
to uh home of bond scott i gotta go see
his gravesite you know
pay my respects and go all the way
through
i don't know all the way back work my
way all the way back to sydney
and maybe have time to check out the
great barrier reef see that's what i
want to do
that's the game plan for me
all right and if the bruins can win the
stanley cup over the next [ __ ] six
seven days it would just be a perfect
goddamn year all right
so anyways that is the podcast this week
everybody once again thank you to
everyone who came out in uh and buffalo
oh i keep
forgetting to tell that story we're
drinking afterwards the hotel bar slo
uh is about ready to shut down and i got
like a 6 40 a.m flight so i'm like well
what's the point of going to bed
so i go across to this bar we start
drinking over there and now their
kitchen was closed so they bring out
some bar food you know they usually
bring out some peanuts or pretzels
they came out and it was all bacon
[Laughter]
i gotta [ __ ] tell you he can't beat
the [ __ ] midwest even though that's
not the midwest it's the beginning of it
and i forgot to mention uh cleveland
uh don't sleep on cleveland i would say
if you're looking to invest some money
in buying an old building if you you
want some friends and you want to make
some [ __ ] money
uh every time i come back to cleveland
it's it's doing a little bit better
and i saw a lot of building going on
there
and it was great to see because whenever
i went to cleveland it always made me
sad like i was because you you know i
was looking at these beautiful buildings
there was just nobody in them
the same thing when you go to detroit
it's just like uh
you're like [ __ ] man look at these
beautiful houses these beautiful
buildings and there's just like
nobody there or just you know some
zombie looking person in front of it
it's uh it's depressing so in st louis
was another one st louis was another one
that was a scary place to be and
10 years ago you know they still have
this [ __ ] you know
some people who were late to the show or
couldn't come to the show because there
was a shooting or something like that so
whatever everybody's got this [ __ ]
but it was nice to see those cities are
starting to make a comeback
um you know after all the manufacturing
jobs and everything left and [ __ ] so i
yeah i actually learned some [ __ ] about
buffalo first
city uh in in the united states that had
electricity
throughout the whole thing this used to
be known as the city of lights how funny
is that
buffalo you don't think of that [ __ ] but
i guess the eerie canal or some [ __ ]
damn i don't know what the [ __ ] it was
created a bunch of
jobs and then they built another dam or
a canal
somewhere else up the [ __ ] river and
everybody left and that was the end of
it
you know everybody left all the [ __ ]
left
you know but all the tough people stayed
and that's why they have an outdoor
stadium
if those [ __ ] stayed the buffalo
bills would play in a dome stadium
that's actually true
all right so there you go that's the
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourselves
my next date i have coming up
is uh the cape cod melody tent
in hyannis massachusetts um tickets are
on sale
um i hope people come out to that one
that's a huge one
because for me because i only saw george
carlin once in my life
unfortunately i only saw him perform one
time and i saw him at the cape cod
melody tent
in like 1988 i've told that story he
absolutely blew me away
uh dennis blair opened him up blew me
away it was just it was [ __ ] awesome
and uh to actually be going back there
25 years later
to be literally doing what i saw him
doing is is [ __ ] amazing so uh
thanks to everyone who's coming out to
that show all right enough with the feel
good vibes go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk
to you next week
go bruins
you